i will say ro and
at the time you and i weren't uh as uh
friendly as we are now
um but i was a little hurt when you
chose bernie over me
well you didn't do a warfare's
resolution with me andrea i mean if you
were a congressman we had tried to stop
the yemen war together
uh you know i would have picked you up
for watching
how it is you and bernie there trying to
pass laws trying to keep the us
out of wars and just because i wasn't
there
you didn't know i'm i mean i'm just one
of my favorite moments from the
presidential debate is when you uh
told elizabeth warren uh you know oh
you're so excited elizabeth warren had
read your book and i thought
what a moment of humanity because i'm in
the process of writing the book and i
had the same thought i'd loved it i'd be
thrilled if
elizabeth warren uh read my book and
bernie sanders and so
uh it was this i don't know if you
remember the moment but i remember
i remember that you're writing a book
that's very exciting um
can you share what it's about sure it's
actually about
expanding access to the digital economy
and in rural
communities and black and brown
communities but more broadly also
applying the principles of democracy
uh to the digital age this idea that uh
the social media platforms that just by
creating platforms of communication
that we'd somehow have more deliberation
or pieces turned out not to be true
partly because they've targeted us you
mean the social media companies haven't
made us all smarter bro we're not all
like much more sophisticated
and educated unfortunately not but it's
the
it's the early stages right i mean the
interesting thing with the printing
press you go back you look at the
history
it took like hundreds of years when the
printing press actually because of
written works was
leading the reactions of actually war
and conflict and it took building of
liberal institutions
to now come to a consensus that the
printing press obviously is a great
dissemination of knowledge but that it
wasn't also creating
violent reactions so we're just 20 years
into social media
it could be enormous in organizing but
we've got to think through
what are the forms of communication the
rules of communication and how do we
give people more choice and not have uh
targeting based on
based on our uh data and in the ways
that facebook has been
doing it well that's one of the things
you're trying to solve for
with your internet bill of rights um so
you're in the midst of this in a way
that very few others are
my sense of things is that there are
some very well intended legislators like
yourself
who understand what's going on with
their data that is getting sold and
resold in ways that are
bad for democracy bad for our mental
health uh bad economics and that you
know it's worth hundreds of billions of
dollars and we're not seeing a dime
the financial incentives are not serving
us well uh and then you have your home
state of california that's actually the
leader
in uh consumer data rights my sense of
things
is that this legislation is kind of
stuck in congress
and that it's more likely that various
states end up following california's
lead
then that congress passes something that
mirrors uh
the california privacy act is that
accurate because i'm sure you have your
finger on the pulse of what the
legislation looks like and i hope i'm
wrong because i'd be doubt there were
federal legislation
we may get federal legislation with
shikaski but let me
go into some detail here because i know
you and and your listeners will
appreciate it
here's the challenge with both the gdpr
in europe and
uh california's uh consumer rights and
why we need a beefed up
ftc and fcc and the federal government
that
one look at the european i funds
yesterday or a couple days ago i read
that
italy found that facebook misused
their uh their data so they're finding
them
seven million dollars i mean give me a
break the facebook's not going crazy you
know
you saw illinois there was a civil
settlement for 650 million dollars which
at least like would hit their radar
screen
you know probably it's an intern would
known as a seven million dollar fine
the second thing is that this is a the
more important they get
so when they have these consent it turns
out there was this paper done
that these tech companies have been able
to graphics and placement
basically get people to click on uh
yes i consent almost 80 90 percent of
times
no one knows what we're agreeing to none
of us i mean you and i went to law
school we still have no idea what we're
agreeing to half the time exactly and so
even with all the good language at the
gym here so what does this mean we
actually need like tech
competent people in enforcement agencies
at the ftc fcc and we've got to have
uh very uh then at the table in
in in defining these laws i don't think
the state by state approach or just the
european approach
is going to be any match for these
companies when i see them they're in my
district
uh and so we absolutely need federal
legislation but more than that we need
the enforcement
and tech competent people in those
agencies who can say no you can't have
manipulative design these dark patterns
that basically are manipulating people
into consent
what do you see as the prospects of uh
federal legislation and these
enforcement resources that could
actually balance the scales
because i agree with you that right now
government is outcome
well i think we it's going to take more
people caring about it right for so long
it was just
that's just a techie issue it's just
privacy why should i care about privacy
here's why you should care because 64 of
people on facebook who joined q anon
were there with facebook recommendations
to join you're now on these public
facebook made some money off of it yeah
the whole thing is messed up
so if you care about the radicalization
of our country and the polarization on
social media
we've got to care about how our
information is being used not just
because of your privacy
because your privacy decision affects
the state of our democratic discourse
and so
what the reason we don't have action on
this frankly is we don't have the
mobilization no one is out there on my
very few people are calling me and
saying bro we need privacy legislation
we need social media regulated they're
calling me
saying understandably we need 15 minimum
wage and other issues but until we have
mobilization
this is just going to continue to be
stalled
i'm 100 with you that most people don't
understand the urgency
of federal data
and privacy legislation and enforcement
resources because right now the tech
companies are running circles around
everybody
uh and and there's not even like uh like
a
a principal debate that's happening that
that is accurate at all like most
legislatures just don't understand the
set of issues
well one thing i really admired about
your presidential campaign is you had a
clear theory of the case which i
happen to share which is in part that
we're going through a digital revolution
that is fundamentally transforming
society it's
leaving communities out of wealth
generation and out of the possibility of
staying in their own communities and
doing well
and it's also making it much diff more
difficult to have
democratic conversation but it's sort of
like we're going and attacking
uh discrete parts of the issue without
seeing that there's this
huge centralized disease in the middle
of it man the center
like like the social media networks like
this tentacle beast in the middle of the
whole thing
if someone wanted to help would it be
helpful if they were to reach out to
their member of congress and say hey
like get behind this federal data
legislation like what can the average
citizen do
absolutely so shikowski's uh bill is the
is the uh the bill on privacy
legislation that would
get passed and it's still being uh
worked on but i think just being part of
the conversation and saying this is
something that we ought to care about
having ideas sending us there
the ideas for that uh and it's and
insisting that this should be part of
the agenda for
uh 2022 that this has to be
a high priority let's do it people write
your members of congress let them know
that you think the fed should pass
legislation protecting our data rights
and making it so that there's actual
enforcement of those rights and that's
not the tech company is laughing all the
way to the bank uh so that's one thing
you're working on but that's not even
the main thing
um you're working on uh trying to get
cash out to people is that correct which
obviously
i am 100 behind
[Laughter]
well you helped with helping tim ryan
and i conceived of this we were calling
for this in march with with your
advocacy at help which said let's get
people two thousand dollar checks and
partly i read one of the most compelling
studies which is that
so many people i think i read up to 75
percent of people are unemployed aren't
getting the unemployment
and i had to re-read it to really get
that sure that's
true yeah so yeah but people either
don't know about it or don't have the
wherewithal to be able to get them so
the best way is just get people these
checks
uh and uh they will spend it locally
they'll
make sure they want their houses aren't
getting foreclosed on they'll be able to
help with rent or help the small
business landlords i mean a lot of
people who aren't
uh paying the rent we're forgetting
about the small businesses that are
being hurt so
i don't understand why if we find these
trillions of dollars to be
bailing out everything else eight
trillion is what we've spent uh
so far as a as a country why we can't
get some of the money for the work again
so you say it's eight carries was like
2.2
uh are you including this massive number
that went to the
uh financial markets like uh yeah did
you get to eat
yeah that's what i read with them when
you look at what both the fed has done
and and the uh and what the congress has
done
and of course there were a number of
other packages uh as well if you sum up
all of that
uh that is about the spending but the
the american people
does the eight include the new 1.9 that
we think will pass in march
no no no this is before so it'll be 10.
and it'll be 10 by the time someone
should do this someone should have a
breakdown of how much money directly
went to the american people
and how much did the government spend
and
you know it makes no sense why you
wouldn't have both
it makes no sense at all man i mean i
tried to do the math on the cares act
and you could have given every american
um
like six thousand dollars for the amount
that was in the cares act instead of
what do we get i think we got
uh well maybe 1200 yeah yeah like you
could have
like you know made that five times
bigger and still had money to spare
[Music]
you